this is not about how to change the
world we're saying that we should stop
fighting against from corruption poverty
oppression racism this is simply about
you
[Music]
[Music]
yesterday I drove an outside of Cape
Town with my family to view the snow a
rare occurrence us kept onions hardly
get to experience it was then when it
hit me we need to celebrate more but not
in the traditional sense prismatic
[Music]
but in a way to celebrate life and our
time on earth which we all seem to be
rushing through for what
[Music]
let's celebrate being young let's
celebrate love can celebrate family
let's celebrate our food for no reason
let's celebrate the city we live in your
home having ability to be able to watch
this video is a privilege having
accessibility
every day I see these negative things on
Facebook back back my life is stupid
ransom are pointless [ __ ] let's change
that to positive appreciation
[Music]
today I decided to go outside with the
purpose of finding positivity and
happiness
this is what I found
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
stop listening to answer and just listen
to understand that your time here is
worth celebrating
[Music]
looking at your life as an outsider it's
more beautiful than you can ever imagine
embrace it
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]